es posible que a usted oa alguien que
conoce le hayan diagnosticado diabetes
tipo 2 este vídeo le mostrará algunas
maneras para ayudarle a controlarla
existen pasos que puedes seguir que
pueden ayudarlo a mantener su glucosa en
sangre o azúcar dentro de un rango
normal esto puede ayudarlo a evitar las
complicaciones de la diabetes tipo 2 se
puede realizar a través de una
combinación de comer una dieta saludable
y realizar ejercicios en forma regular
y tomar medicamentos como se lo indicó
su médico según sea necesario
es posible que algunas personas también
necesiten revisar su azúcar en sangre
como lo indicó su médico
comer una dieta saludable puede ayudar a
disminuir el nivel de azúcar en su
sangre usted puede ayudar a hacerlo al
comer una dieta con frutas vegetales y
granos enteros
sírvase las comidas y los refrigerios
aproximadamente a la misma hora todos
los días los hidratos de carbono son
sustancias que su cuerpo utiliza para
fabricar energía como el equilibrio
apropiado de hidratos de carbono
proteínas y grasas y reduzca la toma de
alimentos con alto contenido de azúcar
y realizar ejercicios en forma regular
incluso solo 30 minutos al día puede
disminuir su nivel de azúcar en sangre y
puede llevar a la pérdida de peso hablé
con su médico antes de comenzar un
programa de ejercicios
es posible que necesite tomar uno o más
medicamentos orales o inyectables para
diabéticos para ayudar a disminuir el
azúcar en sangre algunos de estos
medicamentos pueden aumentar la cantidad
de insulina que fabrica su páncreas
otros reducen la resistencia a la
insulina en sus músculos esqueléticos
algunos medicamentos hacen que ciertos
tejidos sean más sensibles a la insulina
otros causan que su sistema digestivo
consuma menos azúcar
algunos medicamentos permiten que las
sustancias químicas útiles de su sistema
digestivo permanezcan activas por más
tiempo estas sustancias químicas ayudan
a disminuir el nivel de azúcar en su
sangre otros medicamentos ayudan a su
páncreas a liberar la insulina cuando su
azúcar en sangre es alta también reducen
la liberación de insulina cuando el
azúcar en sangre es baja
y algunos medicamentos aumentan la
cantidad de azúcar excretada en la orina
si su diabetes no se puede controlar con
la dieta el ejercicio y otros
medicamentos es posible que su médico
también considere la insulina la
insulina que se inyecta ayuda a
reemplazar la insulina que su cuerpo
produciría normalmente
un profesional de atención médica lo
entrenará para inyectarse la justo
debajo de la piel
quizás deba revisar el nivel de azúcar
en su sangre con un glucómetro
pregúntele a su médico con cuánta
frecuencia debe revisar
para hacerlo pinchar a su dedo con una
pequeña aguja llamada lanceta
luego colocará una gota de sangre en el
glucómetro siguiendo las indicaciones
proporcionadas con su glucómetro en base
al nivel de azúcar en su sangre es
posible que deba ajustar sus comidas
actividad física o dosis de medicamentos
según lo indicó su médico
al tratar y controlar el nivel de azúcar
en su sangre quizás pueda ayudar a
prevenir las complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2
es importante que tome sus medicamentos
como se lo indicó su médico no abandone
sus medicamentos a menos que su médico
le diga que lo haga cuéntele sobre
cualquier efecto secundario que tenga